did you know that every time you flip on
a TV or a radio to a static station
you're seeing or hearing remnants from
the Big Bang sounds crazy doesn't it but
about 1% of that static is actually
coming from something called cosmic
microwave background radiation without
trying to explain the Big Bang in full
about 400,000 years after it began long
before planets and stars formed the
universe was filled with a gas of
protons electrons and photons the
normally electrons having negative
charge and protons having positive
charge tend to get together to create
hydrogen atoms but at this point in time
the universe was extremely hot hot like
the surface of the Sun which is
thousands of degrees and at these
temperatures their kinetic energy is so
high they couldn't come together to form
hydrogen instead it becomes a state of
matter known as electron ion plasma
what's so special about plasma well for
one it's a peg in other words the other
component in the universe we talked
about photons or light can't pass
through it instead the light gets
tripped up by the plasma and doesn't
travel very far at all
over time as the universe expanded all
the plasma that filled up its space
began to cool as it cooled it reached a
point at which the electrons and protons
could unite to form hydrogen which is
electrically neutral this caused the
universe to become transparent suddenly
the photons unobstructed could travel
freely through space at that time most
of these photons were within the visible
light spectrum but over the past ten
billion years or so they got stretched
out enormous ly due to the universe
expanding these photons have been
propagating through the universe ever
since the Big Bang as a very cold and
diffused photon gas in the microwave
band and it just so happens that
antennas for older televisions and radio
are sensitive to microwave frequencies
so when you see or hear that noise well
much of it is radiation from things like
the Sun soil or electronics some of it
is literally a part of the light of
creation itself here since the beginning
of time and while you may not be able to
specifically differentiate it you can
see it and hear it with your very own
eyes and ears light as old as time
you